our liberals fighting turning on masks
the same people who Force folks to cover
up are now freaked out that criminals
keep wearing masks while robbing stores
left and right in democrat-run cities
New York mayor Eric Adams thinks it's
time for a ban
we need to use the technology we have
available to identify those shoplifters
and those who are committed serious
crime when you see these mask wearing
people oftentimes it's not about being
fearful of the pandemic is fearful of
the police catching them for their deeds
and we're really putting the call out
but this about face on mass could be too
late and democrat-run Portland Walmart
will finally close its last two stores
and lay off 600 workers after
record-breaking thefts so I mean this is
basically common sense I mean these
people going into the bodega console
double masked up I don't think they're
worried about covet you know it's funny
in the beginning of the pandemic I said
that and like people want nuts guys you
know what it's like Jesse James the
first thing you do is you put a mask
over your face okay look shock crime
isn't just about putting people in jail
crime is about making a community a
neighborhood an area safe so that the
housing prices remain the same same so
businesses can flourish now we're
peeling back a layer of the onion now
what we see is that not only are
employees losing their jobs not only are
customers not able to buy this stuff
they want to buy businesses are going
out of business but now we're seeing
that these individuals are not just not
only going to jail but they're ruining
communities and that's the problem and I
got to tell you I don't want to say it
but I'm going to say it's like the third
time on this show Eric Adams is starting
to impress me he gives them the ability
to take in people who are mentally ill
gives the cops that ability recognizes
the importance of prayer I mean for me
that's kind of you know important and
this I mean why are they wearing masks
and here's the deal you could say you
know I'm afraid of everybody else well
you're stupid because they already came
out and said Mass don't matter they
don't protect you right so what you do
is you you go into the store and they
have they can ID you with the technology
but then you can put the mask on when
you're in the store so that's a great
thing to engineering complementing
Democrats yep what's going on here
Heraldo well I like Eric Adams very much
I have been a firm supporter of his I
liked him when he was a cop I've known
him since then we've spent some time
together recently crime is very much on
his mind uh Jesse he fears for the city
uh this is a very practical approach to
some of the Casual crime and some of the
premeditated stick-ups that you're
seeing uh you know you you defeat the
most elaborate security system by
wearing a hoodie and putting a mask on
so I I think that you know putting a
sign up no mask on no service you gotta
or a mask is off here or you have double
doors the way they do in many jewelry
stores nowadays I think you have to
start protecting retail the way you
protect uh Banks and some of the
precious assets the critics say Dana
that you're putting the onus on the
bodega owner to say hey you
before you come in here drop the mask uh
Paul Morrow who I know you all know
pretty well he's been on air he was on a
newsroom on Monday talking about how the
NYPD often comes up with some sort of
creative solution and that he said this
really isn't going to help the bodega
owner but it will help these bigger
stores that are gone up and down Fifth
Avenue where you have the smash and
grabs because if they know that they're
they're gonna have to show their face
they might just be a deterrent but the
real problem also for the bodegas is the
robberies and then the a point about the
Walmart's closing is that they're not
it's not the only stores that are going
through this and it's not because of
masks and I think that this is the
beginning of well not just the beginning
we're in the middle of decline Okay so
the policy trade-offs are what's
happening here these maybe they're
unintended consequences okay but if you
have prosecutors who will not prosecute
actual crime and stores get looted left
and right the theft is through the roof
the stores can't make money and the
staff who is working at those stores
like at the Walmart might be threatened
by approaching somebody and saying I saw
you take that you need to put it away
they're told they can't do it inevitably
these stores are going to close and then
what's going to happen then the local
Advocates are going to say that's racist
that you're closing the store right and
now there's food deserts where are
people supposed to get their goods and
you're making people travel farther they
can't afford the gas and then it is the
slow decline but it's like the
unintended consequences you think about
the wind farms off the east coast likely
leading to the killing of whales you
think about the president's obsession
with electric vehicles and those car
batteries destroying rainforest lots of
these things happen but if you have
prosecutors who won't prosecute crime
you're going to get more crime and then
stores are going to make the inevitable
decision to leave well said TJ yeah I
mean this talk about an about face on
masks I thought only fauci could do that
uh I think the idea of putting up a sign
is a great one because we know how
criminals follow signs I think we should
all wear buttons that say please don't
mug me yeah I think that'll really work
what a sign is and what a button is
essentially is an excuse not to fight
the real problem and to fight the real
problem that you need a ton of cops all
of this stuff is happening because the
lack of foot foot patrols if cops are
the best deterrent right and they got to
be allowed to do their job we've we've
we've reduced these these uh patrols
we've reduced the then the retirees and
also we've take we basically handcuffed
them so that's why this is happening uh
you know how did this also start well
shoplifters at least in California
realize they could steal up to 900 bucks
and they wouldn't get prosecuted so
there was a 900 uh uh do not passcode do
not go to jail so they all did it and I
thinking like you know that the illegal
immigration bus movement thing was such
a good thing we should just take these
guys when they get busted and drive them
to the homes of the politicians and just
let them out it's not about the illegal
immigration
it's not it's our own native born okay
please let somebody tell Geraldo that
he's not listening to me again
wait can I can I just make my point my
point is the people that were
responsible for the bills that said it
was okay to steal should feel the
consequences has nothing to do with
illegal immigration open your ears open
your ears one of the good things Greg is
the fact that one of the legislators in
Washington is coming up with a bill that
says now we're going to make any crime
where the theft is over 450 instead of
900. we're going to make it criminal so
they're dropping that that that ceiling
now which is great but they had to veto
the DC crime bill that was soft on crime
in a city that was plagued by crime they
sure did I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now